[Music]
hello and welcome to the NewsHour we
start with our breaking news story out
of occupied East Jerusalem where at
least seven people including a 15 year
old boy have been killed in a shooting
near a synagogue Israeli Medics say
several people are injured gunman was
shot dead at the scene shooting took
place in the illegal settlement of
Nevada it happened a day after Israeli
forces killed 10 Palestinians in the
occupied West Bank
well since the shooting there have been
reports of attacks on Palestinians five
Palestinians have been wounded in beta
one of them is in a critical condition
according to local sources they were
blocking a road when a settler shot at
them settlers have also attacked
Palestinian cars south of Bethlehem and
a farmer near Salford
although deadly shooting has been
celebrated by some people in the
occupied Palestinian territories
oh
[Applause]
there was spontaneous demonstrations in
Gaza and the town of Ramallah in the
West Bank dozens of people came out onto
the streets waving flags and singing the
crowds formed shortly after the
synagogue shooting took place
well James Bay is live for us at the
scene in occupied East Jerusalem and so
James uh reports that the national
security minister Tamar bengavir was
there very briefly what is happening at
the scene now
well he's been joined by prime minister
Netanyahu who is here at the scene let
me just first give you an idea of what
has been going on here and show you
exactly where we are uh if I just step
out of the shot you look up the hill and
you can see two buses up the hill well
that is nebby Yakov that is the
settlement that is where the synagogue
is located and that's where just a
couple of hours after the start of
Shabbat the holy day for Jews this
shooting took place if we come down the
hill you can see the car the Toyota
Corolla that was used in the shooting
we've been watching over the last hour
the police going through that car
looking for any possessions in the car
they've already named in fact there was
a name that came out earlier that was
the wrong name but they've named the
person who was driving the car the
person who carried out the shooting and
they do believe it was just one person
that carried out the shooting Hari Al
welcome he's from the showafat camp
which is very close to navigov located
very close because of course the
geography here is such uh that and is an
illegal settlement has been set up in
land that is designated as Palestinian
land interestingly about the suspect the
Israeli police are saying that they have
no security file on him whatsoever no
previous incidents regarding this man
you might be able to hear in the
distance that way the bit of shooting a
bit a bit of shouting going on from
Palestinian passes by we actually had
some Palestinian passers by here earlier
on and they were dispersed by Israeli
forces with stunned grenades and I
suspect that the Israelis May well move
these people on again because as you
have heard just up the road there right
now not just the security minister but
the Israeli Prime Minister Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu who previously before
he arrived at the scene about 20 minutes
ago was Consulting with his security
Chiefs in fact you might be able to hear
it now the stun grenades being fired
again to disperse the crowds by the
Israeli military
um
worth telling you we haven't don't have
any comments yet from prime minister
Netanyahu but we do have comments uh
from the security minister Ben gavir as
I show you I'm just showing you some
pictures and we'll show you some
pictures where those crowds of
Palestinian youths are being dispersed
by the Israeli Security Forces I think
it's worth telling you what itamar Ben
gavier said he's the controversial
security minister of Israel uh
controversial because he is himself a
champion of settlers I think his words
are important he said we need to react
the situation cannot go on like this and
clearly it's a situation in this region
in the last 24 hours that is really
serious worrying the International
Community greatly that very deadly
attack Israeli raid that took place that
took place in Janine overnight the
bombardment in Gaza the rockets in Gaza
and as you mentioned Mariam in beta
neonabolous in the West Bank after this
incident and almost certainly a reaction
to this incident five Palestinians there
were shot by an Israeli settler and
wounded we understand they were standing
on the road and they were shot by a
settler no more information at this
stage on their injuries
um uh that but we're obviously waiting
for further information on that and
waiting further information on what
exactly prime minister Netanyahu is
going to say and exactly who he's going
to meet as his visit here continues
and James there have been months of uh
clashes that are taking place nearly
every night or very often between
Palestinians and Israeli Security Forces
but the raid that took place in Janine
was the deadliest and the most serious
that has occurred for many years it
resulted in the deaths of nine
Palestinians including an elderly woman
now comes this synagogue shooting and
then also we've been reporting on a bit
of settler violence but also that
happens on a regular basis as well
I suppose there are two things perhaps
one is uh concerns about how what the
response might be whether this could be
the start of an escalation or some sort
of military operation by the Israelis
but then also what it could mean for uh
individual sort of protests and and
settler violence amongst people on the
ground
well I think we need to listen closely
to the words of the Israeli Prime
Minister when he actually speaks which
we believe he will do as he is there in
Nevada but as I reported a moment ago
the security minister saying that there
will be a reaction suggests there is
going to be something coming from the
Israeli side and that creates as ever in
these sort of circumstances potentially
a spiral it is a very worrying situation
yes the events of the last 24 hours are
really worrying and Grim but also
remember where we are this year a record
number of Palestinians killed at the
start of this year on top of 2022 a
record number of Palestinians killed in
2022 it's a grim situation we have this
new Israeli government the most
hard-line Israeli government in history
and it's it's difficult to see where
things are going to go but I don't think
anyone watching this any Observer
whether they're here on the ground or
whether The Observers from the
International Community thinks it's
going to it thinks it's going to go
um in in in in in a good direction uh
just showing you a convoy leaving now we
believe that is the Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu leaving from
uh naviakov having completed a quick
visit but of course for security
concerns he wouldn't hang around for
long uh we we saw we've seen some
pictures of him with his security
minister Ben gavier we're not aware what
words he spoke but clearly we're likely
to get some quotes from the Israeli
Prime Minister from the Press who were
who are there with him uh I would think
in the coming hours which may give us
more of an indication let me more of the
Convoy coming
coming down the street with their Sirens
blazing this is all part of the security
for Israel's leader after his visit uh
to the place to the synagogue where in
recent hours seven people were killed uh
including a 15 year old boy the the uh
the number of people injured has been
varying and and it's gone down a bit and
that's only because of course the death
toll has gone up uh but uh we think
three people currently injured they
include we're told a woman who is
critically ill very very seriously ill
we understand uh in terms of the latest
information that we're getting on the
injuries
okay thank you very much from occupied
use Jerusalem not far from the scene of
that synagogue shooting James Bay's
reporting
well Al jazeera's Ahmed mahrez on the
phone now he joins us from Ramallah to
discuss these I think there have been
three incidents of settler violence one
in beta another on a farmer near Salford
and then we were speaking Ahmed about
also a bit of settler violence south of
Bethlehem do you have any more
information about these reprisal attacks
against Palestinians
responsibility
like we we can say that uh five
Palestinians uh at least were wounded
and we got an update that one of them is
in critical condition they were wounded
in one incident of settlers attack
attack premium cars near the village of
beta which is very close to the City of
Minneapolis and occupied under occupied
West Bank of course the attack follows
the uh I've got a Finland shooting in
occupied these Jerusalem in which seven
Israelis have been confirmed that so far
and of course as James was just saying
the tensions had been high since uh the
uh yesterdays
deeply as well even military incursion
into the genuine refugee camp when a
nine Palestine Engineers uh adult
Fighters and civilians were killed
during the Israeli military raid in the
Janine Refugee calendar occupied West
Bank
and we have seen unrest in the West Bank
uh really intensifying over the last
year or so particularly since that raid
in the Janine refugee camp people that
bracing themselves for for more violence
for more trouble
well actually they are saying
um the Israeli heavy-handed approach and
the continuing killings arrests and
waves and over the last year in
particular will only stroke the cycle of
violence and hatred and bloodshed and
they are exhausted because the Israeli
waves especially into the two cities in
the occupied West Bank of Germany and
that was have become again nightmare as
you say and a daily routine
thank you very much for joining us
bringing us up to speed with um what's
been happening there thank you